الى التطورات الميدانيه لحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا حيث اكدت هيئه الاركان العامه
الاوكرانيه ان قواتها افشلت هجمات للقوات
الروسيه في ضواحي بخموت الشماليه بينما
اعلنت الدفاع الروسيه اسقاط صاروخ من نوع
ستورماني الصنع على وقع هذه التطورات
الميدانيه اجرى رئيس الاوكراني زيلينسكي
مباحثات مع رئيس الوزراء البريطاني في
زياره خاطفه قام بها اليوم الى شمال
غربلندا وللمتابعه ينضم الينا من ميكوليف
مراسل الجزيره تامر الصمادي من موسكو امين
درغامي ومن لندن محمد المدهون وابدا معك
محمد من هذه الزياره اليوم
الى لندن ما الذي سمعه من البريطانيين
نعم مريم هي زياره يختتم بها الرئيس
الاوكراني جوله اوروبيه دار فيها في برلين
وباريس وكان له ايضا وقفه في روما جاء
ليعرب عن امتنانه وتقديره وشكره
للبريطانيين بشان كل الدعم العسكري
والاقتصادي المقدم له له لبلاده خلال
الحرب ولكنه جاء ليطلب المزيد ايضا الكلمه
والعباره الاهم التي قالها الرئيس
الاوكراني هي تحالف الطائرات المقاتله ما
زال زيلينسكي يريد الطائرات المقاتله التي
يعتقد ان بلاده بحاجتها وانها ستزيد من
قدرتها على شن الهجوم المضاد الذي من خلال
زيارته هذه اراد ان يظهر جديه بلاده في شن
هذا الهجوم المضاد وكذلك من خلال
الاستضافه البريطانيه اراد البريطانيون ان
يظهروا جدي وجديه الحلفاء الغربيين في
استمرار هذا الدعم العسكري
لاوكرانيا كانت هناك الكثير ايضا من
الدلالات الرمزيه في هذه الزياره لم ياتي
الى لندن ذهب الى مقر الاقامه الريفي
لرئيس الوزراء البريطاني في تشيكنز وكانت
كان الاجتماع قد عقد في القاعه التي كان
يلقي منها رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه الاسبق
الخطاباته خلال الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وقال سونك ليزيلنسكي انه سيعود مجددا الى
هذه القاعه بعد انتهاء هذه الحرب ولكن
التركيز كل التركيز من الرئيس الاوكراني
كان على الحصول على طائرات مقاتله ليتابع
ما قاله
تحدثنا عن الطائرات المقاتله وهذا موضوع
مهم للغايه بالنسبه لنا لاننا لا نستطيع
التحكم في المجال الجوي
ولاننا شركاء حقيقيون فان ريشي يعرف كل
التفاصيل عن ساحه المعركه نريد انشاء
تحالف الطائرات المقاتله ونحن ايجابيون
بشان وتحدثنا عنه واعتقد انه سيتم اتخاذ
بعض القرارات المهمه جدا في وقت قريب لكن
علينا العمل عليها بشكل اكبر
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني قال ان بلاده
ستكون جزءا اساسيا من هذا التحالف الدولي
ولكنه يتجاوز مجرد تقديم الطائرات الى
تقديم التدريب للطيارين الاوكرانيين وهو
الامر الذي يمكن ان تتعهد به بريطانيا في
هذه المرحله فلنتابع ما قاله سونيك
سنكون جزءا اساسيا من تحالف الدول التي
تقدم الدعم بالطائرات المقاتله واوكرانيا
بناء قدرات طائرات المقاتله ليس امرا
مباشرا وهو ليس مجرد تزويد بالطائرات بل
هناك تدريب للطيارين وكل اللوجيستيات التي
تتعلق بهذا الامر المملكه المتحده يمكن ان
تلعب دورا كبيرا واحد الامور التي سنبداها
قريبا هو تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين ونحن
جاهزون لتنفيذ هذه الخطط في وقت قريب
نسبيا سندرب المواطنين الاوكرانيين
ليصبحوا جاهزين لقياده طائرات مقاتله